[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Cloud Shell
Editor makes it easy
for you to write code
directly in your web browser
and deploy it to the
Cloud, and Cloud Run
makes it easy to
deploy highly scalable
containerized applications
on a fully managed serverless
platform.
So you might be wondering, can I
write the code for my Cloud Run
apps in Cloud Shell Editor?
Yes, you definitely can.
Thanks to its Cloud Code
integration, Cloud Shell Editor
works great with Cloud
Run development workflows,
allowing you to build, deploy,
and debug your application
in just a couple of clicks.
In this video,
we're going to see
how to use Cloud Shell Editor to
deploy an application to Cloud
Run.
Let's go.
First, visit
ide.cloud.google.com
to launch the
Cloud Shell Editor.
On the status bar at the
bottom of your screen,
click Cloud Code.
From the Cloud Code menu,
click New Application,
and then select the
Cloud Run application
for the type of sample
app we want to create.
After that, we'll get a
list of Cloud Run templates
to choose from.
Let's go with the
Python Flask option.
Next, select a folder in
your Cloud Shell environment
to save your application
to, and give it a name.
If that looks good, click
Create New Application.
Cloud Shell Editor
clones the files
for your sample application from
GitHub into a new workspace.
You can see the list of files
in the Explorer panel located
on the left side of the screen.
Now let's go ahead and
deploy the service.
Let's go down to the status
bar again and click Cloud Code.
This time, we'll click
Deploy to Cloud Run.
Click Authorize to authorize
Cloud Shell to make Google
Cloud Platform API calls to
give Cloud Shell Editor access
to your Google Cloud resource.
Since this is the
first time using
Cloud Run in this project,
we're prompted here
to enable the Cloud Run API.
In the Deploy to Cloud Run
dialog, under Service Settings,
we can set the name
for our service.
And under Deployment,
we can select the region
we want it to be deployed to.
Since we want to make
this a public service,
we'll keep Allow Unauthenticated
Invocations selected.
There are some
additional settings
we can adjust, like container
settings, environment
variables, and Cloud
SQL connections.
There are also build
settings, where
you can choose your builder
from Docker and Buildpacks.
For now, we'll leave those
as their default values
and click Deploy.
Cloud Code now
builds your image,
pushes it to the
Container Registry,
and deploys your
app to Cloud Run.
Once you see the message
"Deployment completed
successfully," your service
is live and accessible
via the URL displayed in the
Deploy to Cloud Run dialog.
That was pretty easy, and
updating your Cloud Run app
is just as simple.
Let's redeploy your app with
an update to this message.
Back in our Cloud Shell Editor
from the Explorer panel,
let's open the file app.py.
In the hello function, we'll
find the message variable
that holds the friendly
HTTP greeting we just saw.
Let's update that message.
Cloud Shell Editor automatically
saves all file changes.
Once we make our changes, we
can head back down to Cloud Code
down in the status bar.
Once again, let's click
Deploy to Cloud Run.
This time, the service
we created before
is listed here in
the Service Settings.
Let's hit Deploy to deploy
our updated service.
Once it's done, we can head
back to our deployment URL
and refresh the page.
And there it is.
Our app has been redeployed
with the updated code.
With just a couple
of clicks, we were
able to deploy, update, and
redeploy a simple Cloud Run
application, and we were
able to do it all directly
from our browser window without
having to leave our Cloud Shell
Editor.
Do you want to give
it a try yourself?
Check out the
interactive tutorial
linked in the description
below, or by launching it
from the Cloud Shell
Editor Welcome page.
For more videos on Cloud Shell
Editor and a whole lot more,
make sure to subscribe
to the channel.
Join me next time,
when I'll show you
how easy it is to use Cloud
Shell Editor to deploy
to Google Kubernetes Engine.
See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]